Kamath time yeah we have a trailer for
Game of Thrones Season 4 and I didn't
want to watch it because I don't like
knowing anything about Game of Thrones
before I go into it I don't know this
new season could be about anything could
be about dragons it could be about fire
it could be about a little warming I
don't want to know but a lot of people
wanted to hear me talk about it so I
guess I'll talk about it in which case
yeah I watched it and I'm going to talk
about some spoilers that have already
happened in Game of Thrones so this is a
warning if you haven't seen Game of
Thrones seasons one through three three
in particular you've been warned a
couple things before we get started on
the last trailer review that I did I
said that I do a video on YouTube with
no trailer footage then on my website I
would have one with trailer footage
turns out I need to bide server space
and in order to do that I didn't so
working on all that but here I'll still
do a video with no trailer footage
because I don't know if YouTube is still
killing all firstborns and videos that
use trailer footage I don't know the
status of that till I find out I'm gonna
play it safe because says Lord Baelish
would say I protect my investment but
I'll explain to you what I saw I don't
worry and I'm gonna theorize here so if
you've read the books and you know the
answer don't put spoilers in the
comments section don't be a dick or if
you do put spoilers in the comments
section after you push enter go ahead
and unsubscribe because I obviously
don't like you because you're an
if you put spoilers so since you're not
going to do that don't worry you're not
an
let's talk about this the first shot in
the trailer is just dragon shadow flying
over King's Landing and you're like all
right it could be a couple things
trailer sometimes make up for the
sake of trailers could be that could be
a dream could be the last shot of the
season could be the first shot of the
season I don't know it's intriguing as
hell though because the whole thing is
Daenerys and her dragons and she's gonna
cook she's gonna wreck shop which is
always cracked me up about Game of
Thrones everyone's all fighting they're
warned in the end dragons are gonna come
from here and I saw bees are gonna come
from the north all the politics and
in between it just doesn't matter you
know it does matter the King Saul I'm
sorry sir Jamie Lannister you know any I
got monologue when he was in the bath
with Brienne and he had his nub and he's
telling this story you're like you're no
longer King Slayer
you're Jaime Lannister cuz you're
awesome first time you see me in the
trailer Joffrey's like I went in the
wall and this one dude's like the Wars
not won I was like who is a holy
that's Jaime Lannister he's all clean
shaven he has a haircut he's looks like
dirty bum Jesus for about two seasons
now so I didn't recognise him he gets
new hand he gets this prosthetic metal
hand in which case I was like hey I want
to know if they on great joy has a metal
dick
the dude I want to know he's okay give
him his metal deck yeah when the in
memoriam segments going on the Oscars
this year I want to know that Theon
Greyjoy's dick is recognized that hurts
man that hurts it's like the red wedding
of your nuts it affected me because
usually shows or movies or whatever be
like we're gonna cut it off and then
they don't not Game of Thrones like no
it's gone mailed it to his dad because
that's just how we roll here and then we
see Daenerys and she's building her army
as always and she says this really sweet
line she's talking about the people and
she's like they can either live in my
new world or die in their old world and
I've seen this for a while Daenerys is
such this Jesus chick metaphor with
dragons that she has so much power and
you're like yeah I want to see you
succeed because you're awesome but then
you start thinking what if she gets
corrupted what if she is a Targaryen
their conquerors she starts seeing this
hardcore attitude start coming out of
her as she gets more and more confident
as the seasons have gone on in which
case you have to step back and go what
have you just become a dick by the time
you take the throne your dragons just
eat everything you sit there and you're
like okay let's just hang out and
execute she was banging Khal Drogo
he wasn't known for his bedside manner
and were that one monologues like
beating his chest and he's freaking
out yeah you remember she's married to
that dude she had to have picked up a
few things along with her DNA because
again she's a Targaryen and it looks
like Tyrians in deep you know what
this is why I love Tyrion Lannister it's
really it's a thing with Tyrion
Lannister and the actor Peter Dinklage
together they made being a dwarf awesome
it's like if you were a small dude in
Hollywood before you're gonna play
Santa's helpers and but example
Peter Dinklage is playing Trask in x-men
Days of Future past it just seems like
the doors been open to where it's like
nah it doesn't matter your size as long
as you can pull the roll off visually
it's easy to be like no you can't play
that role he's small fact is Peter
Dinklage is one of the best actors out
there so yeah he can play the role I
just like the fact that doors opened up
I think that that's why Peter Dinklage
is badass and of course we closed the
trailer with peter dinklage tyrion
lanister giving his sage advice he's a--
like if you want justice you've come to
the wrong place you're like are you
gonna die I don't want him to die the
last dude who was rotting in a dungeon
who was awesome
lost his head I'm telling your friends
he's gonna lose a head a hand or a dick
that's the way it's gonna be that's the
Game of Thrones way heads hands and
dicks no one rides for free someone's
losing something but in the end
Game of Thrones is the best show on TV
right now I say right now because
Breaking Bad has wrapped up it's no
longer new episodes on TV
yeah Game of Thrones is vulgar its
violent it's very mature and it's badass
yeah new this is am looking forward to
season four it's gonna be pretty sweet
Game of Thrones Season four have you
seen the trailer you're looking forward
to seeing it there's a part of me is
like if you saw the red wedding and then
you walk from the show I understand I
feel like that's a turning point in
people's entertainment in any case
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more